we're at keleti train station in
Budapest Hungary this is a transit point
for thousands trying to make it to
countries like Germany and Sweden this
is the first of several daily dispatches
we'll be spending as we join refugees on
this leg of what's been a long and
dangerous
so she's saying there's an area over
there that's just for children this is
where they're distributing clothes won't
you be my guest has other guests to look
judge this is all clothing right here
and we have these are donations clothing
the shopping together shopping Hungarian
people have donated these bags are
pounding
tomorrow 30 job Saravanan party
Roger doctor as a resume Alaska we
I can be on Anacapa Oh
so he crossed the border here between
Serbia and Hungary by foot walking
mansions and she's going to take us
inside there's a bit of a medical aid
set up there there's doctors that are
helping treat people so we're gonna go
in there they're telling us about a lot
of the injuries they see here are
related to the feet because people are
walking so much and you can see that his
feet are really just scarred there for
leading this blisters pedometer he's
saying this as dangerous as this journey
is it's better than watching your kid
down in front of your scenario they saw
that skate come out our head getting at
- cinema and asked Alam every city I
need ice booger
why not specific item up still to that
moment I wasn't good pretty good
I mean I would murder a Muslim 800m no
andrea was someone better
this was over I never know how feeling
when I'm able to manifest II know this
trains now headed toward Austria we're
gonna jump on the next one I join
refugees if they cross the border there
you